hey everyone at Perry an atom here yet
again with another TIF 2018 review for
you this one is for a movie I was really
looking forward to and I think Adam was
as well as a book reader we're talking
right now about the sisters brothers so
Adam you want to give us a you're like
the sisters brothers expert to me yes
yeah well it's based on a novel written
by an author named Patrick DeWitt which
I read years ago and absolutely adored
and it's a Western technically it's
directed by Jacques Audiard it's his
first english-language film he's a
French filmmaker he directed a prophet
and rusted bone deep on I think and it
stars walking Phoenix in john c reilly
as eli and Charlie's sisters which is
where the sisters brothers comes from it
is intentionally silly and ridiculous
because the book is as is the tone of
the film as well but it's also really
sad and melancholic and sweet and weird
and strange I mean the film opens the
sisters brothers are hitmen and they get
a new job they are to go and kill a
prospector who was apparently stolen
from their boss named the Commodore this
prospector is played by Riz Ahmed who
you know from Nightcrawler and the
Commodore has sent an advance man to go
and capture the prospector and hold him
until the sisters president sisters
brothers I did it I did it first I do
until the sisters brothers get there to
do the dirty work the advance man is
played by Jake Gyllenhaal and yes yes
and you get a bunch of really great
scenes between Jake Gyllenhaal Riz Ahmed
as they kind of strike up a friendship
and bond before the sisters brothers get
there and it is a Nightcrawler reunion
these four characters are so wonderfully
drawn in this film and it's so
beautifully acted it's pretty insane
Joaquin Phoenix plays one of the sisters
brothers I can't remember who's Charlie
are you like it's Charlie easy like
Joaquin Phoenix is Illinois right we'll
go with that so walking Phoenix's
character is
it kind of petulant very violent he
drinks that I think you're right he
could shoot and kill people at any time
john c reilly
is playing a bit of a sad-sack he's the
one who kind of has to take care of his
younger brother and kind of watch after
him and pick up after his messes RZA
mets prospector is very excited about
it's set in the 1800's that during the
gold rush and excited about prospecting
and this new formula that he has for
prospecting and then Jake Gyllenhaal's
character is very interesting he plays
this man who fancies himself very yes
John Morris he puts on this this accent
of kind of nobility and it's an air of
pretension he's he's pretending he's
pretending that he's better than he
actually is but he finds him he writes
these eloquent notes to the sisters
brothers to tell them you know where
they are and where they're going and a
very funny running gag in the films that
Joaquin Phoenix's character keeps
getting annoyed at the large words that
John Moores keeps using in his notes I
yeah so I would actually I would
actually pluck Jake Gyllenhaal's
character out of the oh of it out of the
equation I love it I yeah you know I
think he is an excellent actor this
reason there was something about it I
think it might have been the accent
where he was the only one where I just
kept looking at him as Jake Gyllenhaal
dressed up in Western gear doing this
accent but I did really like I liked
what was going on between his character
and Rosa met there there was an
interesting interesting bond that was
created because really I mean obviously
you have the sisters brothers and a lot
of this movie was about or at least to
me it was about just the connection with
the people and seeing those
relationships evolved as you make your
way through the American West so seeing
how the two of them I mean seeing how
the two of them kind of grew close
together while the sisters brothers like
never really did like their their
brothers and it's it's basically who
you're stuck with and who you're
obligated to because you're related by
blood but every time john c reilly tries
to get close to joaquin phoenix joaquin
phoenix just you know
basically give some a big fat middle
finger all over again time and time
again but I think what worked best in
the sisters brothers for me and I think
it's what you're gonna hear a lot about
from anybody who reviews this movie is
probably john c reilly yeah john c
reilly is exceptional i need to go
through his IMDB before i say this but
part of me wants to call this his best
performance I've ever seen there's
something about his work in this where I
think just his casting in this
particular role was so perfect because I
think he's able to capture capture
bumbling but capable at the same time
and I think that's what this character
needed but also you know he was heavily
involved with the creation of this movie
from the very beginning and I was aware
of that when I went into the movie and I
could see that on screen he got it
there's something about this character
in this story that he clearly got very
strongly and cared deeply about and I
think in this case it really comes
through super strongly but I think the
sisters brothers work so well and I did
like RZA meds take on on warm too I
think he had a really interesting
demeanor and yeah kind of like a swagger
to him that I didn't really quite expect
but I was loving the brother so much
that sometimes I had a difficult time
being ripped away from them and put back
into the other duo scenario but then
once I was with them long enough I would
get into them again but I would always
be happy to go back to you and Charlie
yeah Riley's performance I mean it's a
great reminder that he is one of our
most reliable dramatic performers I mean
people forget that like he was in three
Best Picture nominees in one year with
the our Chicago and gangs in New York he
was in the Aviator after that he was
kind of the guy you would go to for the
solid dramatic supporting performance
then of course he met Adam McKay and
stepbrothers and Talladega Nights and
stuff but this is a really great return
to that dramatic acting it's a really
sad heartfelt performance and this is a
film if you're really into plot and
story you may be frustrated by this film
because it's not necessarily about that
it's really more about the characters in
the journey it's a it's ultimately a
melancholic Western it's about kind of
hopes and dreams
but also how lethal it is I mean the
sisters brothers are out here killing
people for a living for what and that's
kind of that's kind of what they come
about too as they go along and is kind
of you you see the internal struggle
externalized in terms of like this is
literally going to kill them and and
what is what is the reason for them
doing something like this as as an
occupation the film is super eloquent it
never really hits that on the head no
character ever says this is what the
movies about it's just very very sweet
and yeah weird and strange a lot of what
you just articulated comes through most
I think from RISM ed and John see
Riley's performance to where they never
actually say anything except I guess I
guess now I'm afraid to use the
character names coming from them but i
think john c reilly does express that in
a way to joaquin phoenix a couple of
times and it's just warms his outlook on
life and what he's trying to achieve
where it isn't necessarily about the
money I think that really spoke to me
too and I appreciated that ultimately
I came down to a B+ with this one you
know it's funny what you said before
about you know if you like plot heavy
things and I do I like a very specific
journey but I think when you have that
kind of nut I wouldn't necessarily call
this a slice of life film but a film
where you kind of just exist in a world
with particular characters and they
don't necessarily have this end game
that they're getting to sometimes that
can frustrate me it didn't hear it
didn't hear and I think it is primarily
because I was so drawn to john c reilly
and i was i really believed in what he
was trying to get for himself in life
and and i appreciated that yeah it's a
character piece it's very much a
character driven story but it's shot
gorgeously it's just kind of living with
these characters for the runtime I gave
it up B plus I really really like this
Bowman and if you like the film or if
you're curious to read the book before
the film know that they're very very
similar in tone so I had someone who
loved the book I did didn't know how
they were going to go in to adapt it
because it had kind of this Coen
Brothers kind of
wry wit to it and the trailers gotta
lean a little bit on the comedy and it
is funny yeah it's got a caustic wit to
it but it's not a comedy necessarily
it's funny it's also got one one
particularly horrific moment that you
will know it when you see it but I
couldn't shake it for a very long time
probably still can't shake it right now
but you're gonna have to figure it out
when you see the sisters brothers thank
you guys so much for watching this
review as always don't forget to like
and share it
check out collider.com for even more
TIFF commercial see soon
[Music]